In April 1851, Alfred C. Hobbs boarded the
steamship Washington bound for Southampton,
England.
His official duty was to sell the New York
City-based company Day and Newell’s newest
product – the parautopic lock – at a trade
show – London’s Great Exhibition.
But Hobbs had something a bit more nefarious
up his sleeve, or rather in the small trunk
that accompanied him on the ship.
In it sat a large assortment of picks, wrenches,
rakes, and other slender tools.
You see, Hobbs wasn’t just trying to sell
his locks.
He was trying to prove that his competitors’
locks were, quite simply, not good enough.
He had the tools, skills, and charisma to
do just that.
Alfred Hobbs was about to launch the Great
Lock Controversy of 1851.
Of all the locks at the Great Exhibition in
July of 1851, the “Detector” was thought
of as top of the class.
Patented in 1818 by Jeremiah Chubb, it had
become the most widely used and prestigious
lock throughout England.
In fact, in 1823 Chubb was given the distinguished
honor of being the sole supplier of locks
for England’s post offices and “Her Majesty’s
Prison Service.”
Chubb_lockBy 1851, Chubb & Son and their “Detector”
lock was so highly respected that they were
given the assignment of creating a special
security display cage that housed the great
Koh-i-Noor diamond, a 186 carat diamond that
currently sits in the Crown of Queen Elizabeth
which is locked in the Tower of London.
Numerous picklocks in London had made attempts
at getting past the Detector with no success.
In one instance, a picklock who had been imprisoned
was offered his freedom if he could figure
out a way to pick the Detector lock.
He couldn’t do it.
What made the Detector so difficult was that
the lock had a built in anti-lock picking
mechanism which, if triggered, would render
the lock inoperable, even if you had the key.
This trap worked such that if you lifted one
of the pins beyond what the key would have
done, it triggered the lockdown mechanism.
By this, you could also tell if someone had
tried to pick the lock, if your key suddenly
stopped working.
To get the lock to work again, a special regulating
key was needed, which would reset the lock
such that it could be opened once again with
the normal key.
The “Detector” was thought to be in a
lock class all to itself.
That is, until Hobbs got to it.
According to a report filed by Benji Johnson,
“an agent of the state of New York appointed
to attend” the Great Exhibition, Hobbs wasted
very little time in proving that Chubb’s
locks were not impenetrable.
As the report read, “Soon after the exhibition
opened, Mr. A.C. Hobbs, of New York, who had
charge of Day and Newell’s locks, obtained
one of Chubb’s locks and opened it in a
space of 10 or 15 minutes, in the presence
of several gentlemen.”
As one would imagine, this did not sit well
with many an Englishmen who were using the
Detector to lock away their homes and valuables;
most of all, it did not sit well with Chubb
& Son.
They challenged Hobbs to try something a tad
more difficult, a Chubb’s lock attached
to an iron door of a vault in Westminster
that was a “depository of valuable papers.”
Hobbs sent out an invitation for them to come
watch him pick, “Gentlemen- An attempt will
made to open a lock of your manufactured on
the door of a strong room…
You are respectfully invited to be present
and witness the operation.”
At approximately 11:35 am, in front of the
iron door in Westminster, Hobbs met his skeptical
onlookers.
He took out from his “waistcoat two or three
small and simple-looking tools – a description
of which, for obvious reasons, we fear to
give” and went to work.
Within twenty five minutes, he had the lock
open with a “sharp click.”
He had once again successfully picked a supposedly
impenetrable Chubb lock.
Witnesses, hardly believing their eyes, asked
him to do it again.
So, he relocked the lock and picked it again.
This time in seven minutes and “without
the slightest injury to the lock or door.”
England’s illusion of the security of their
possessions had been shattered.
After making his presence quite known at London’s
Great Exhibition, Hobbs continued his lock
picking tour in England.
For instance, later that summer, he picked
the “monster” Bramah Precision lock, which
had never been picked since it was manufactured
in 1790.
This scared the Bank of England enough that
they had all of their locks swapped out for
Day & Newell’s.
Dubbed by the newspaper “The Great Lock
Controversy,” the London Times wrote, “We
believed before the Exhibition opened that
we had the best locks in the world,” but
no longer after Hobbs’ demonstrations.
Skeptics doubted Hobbs’ ability, asking
if the locks were picked properly, if he had
cheated, or even, if they hadn’t seen it
themselves, that it was all an urban myth.
Even major publications, while admitting that
Hobbs did do what was asked, doubted his skills.
Said Bankers’ Magazine, “the result of
the experiment has simply shown that, under
a combination of the most favourable circumstances,
and such as practically could never exist,
Mr. Hobbs has opened the lock.”
So how did Hobbs acquire his prodigious lock
picking skills?
Hobbs father died when Hobbs was just three
years old, so as soon as he could work, he
did so to help support his family.
Thus, at the age of ten, he began his professional
career as a farmhand.
He eventually moved to wood carving, carriage
building, tinsmithing, and harness making.
Around 1835, he earned an apprenticeship with
the Sandwich Glass Company (now a museum sixty
miles outside of Boston) where he learned
to make doorknobs and the locks that went
with them; he soon also became very talented
at picking those locks.
He took those skills to Day & Newell and quickly
became a very good salesman.
After all, what’s a better way to sell locks
than to easily pick your competitors’ locks
in front of your potential customers?
Before showcasing this talents to Britain
in 1851, Hobbs picked his way across America.
He hopped from town to town calling on banks
to challenge him to open their safes, all
in the name of selling Day & Newell locks,
of course, and sometimes for prize money.
For instance, according to a story recounted
in A History of the Old Town of Stratford
and the City of Bridgeport, Connecticut written
in 1888, while on a job in Lancaster, PA replacing
locks at a bank in 1848, a cashier showed
him a newspaper ad placed by a “Mr. Woodbridge,
of Perth Amboy” offering $500 (about $11,000
today) to the person who could open the lock
on the safe in the New York’s Merchant Exchange
reading room (now the National City Bank Building
at 55 Wall Street) within thirty days.
Hobbs proclaimed to the clerk, “That is
my money” and left for New York right after
finishing the job in Lancaster.
Hobbs met his challenger in New York and after
parameters were set: three arbitrators were
to oversee; he must use instruments of his
own; and if he was not able to open the lock,
Hobbs would have to sign a certificate declaring
the lock perfectly safe and recommend it to
the public.
Woodbridge’s lock was extremely cleverly
designed.
Besides having 479,001,600 possible arrangements
of the pins, it was “rigged” such that
if the bolt was pulled before the tumblers
were perfectly set, anything in the lock would
be seized and you’d be unable to remove
it, thus making the lock impossible to pick
at this point with tool(s) stuck inside it.
So the picklock couldn’t try to open the
lock until he or she knew the tumblers were
set just so.
After everyone went home for the day, Hobbs
was given access to the safe and began work
on the lock at nine pm.
In just two and a half hours, he had figured
out the correct setting for the pins, and
laced a thin metal wire into the lock to pull
the bolt.
Of course, he needed the arbitrators to witness
what he’d done to get credit, so he waited
until the following morning when they could
be called upon.
At ten am the next morning.
Mr. Woodbridge, who Hobbs had requested attend
him along with the arbitrators, found Hobbs
standing in front of the safe with a crowd
surrounding him.
Again from A History of the Old Town of Stratford
and the City of Bridgeport, Connecticut:
Mr. Woodbridge came and there being quite
a crowd around, he called from a distance:
“Hallo, Mr.Hobbs, what is the trouble?”
“There is something the matter with the
lock,” said Mr. Hobbs.
“What is it?” said Mr. Woodbridge.
Mr. Hobbs then carefully moving the wire,
pulled the door of the safe open and said,
“Your lock won’t keep the door shut.”
Carrying around an extensive set of lock picks
during his trip to England wasn’t exactly
a recipe for smooth relations with the bobbies
who didn’t know who he was.
As such, along with his box of lock picking
tools, Hobbs also carried with him a letter
from the Chief of Police of New York City,
George Matsell, vouching for Hobbs’ character.
1851 was a rather vulnerable time for English
citizens.
It was the first time that England’s urban
population outnumbered the rural population,
meaning more people gathered in small spaces
which made security more of an issue.
Additionally, the Great Exhibition had brought
citizens from across the world, foreigners,
to London and to the untrusting eyes of its
citizens.
Plus, a rising middle class valued their possessions
and property immensely and wanted to guard
it.
All of this rendered Alfred Hobbs and his
lock picking skills both a point of fear and
admiration.
Chubb’s locks, despite its humiliation,
continued as Britain’s industry standard.
In fact, Chubb still operates today making
safes that are “trusted the world over.”
Alfred Hobbs stayed in London for nine years
and began his own lock manufacturing company,
Hobbs Hart Company.
He eventually returned to the US in 1860,
but the company stayed in London, on 76 Cheapside
Ave., bearing its famous name.
It remained there for another ninety plus
years, until 1954, when it was bought, by
the Chubbs Company.
Hobbs, upon returning to the United States,
didn’t go back into locks.
He worked at the Howe Sewing Machine Company,
helping Elise Howe engineer and design the
lock-stitch sewing machine.
Eventually, he joined the Remington Arms Company
at the request of the company’s founder
Marcellus Hartley, who was looking for a “mechanical
genius.”
Hobbs proved to be just that, filing a dozen
patents for the company in firearm ammunition
manufacturing.